tyler's coming off of his
best start and what we have seen in a
long time 11 strikeouts the last time
out and he did give up the couple of
home runs in the first inning but i
thought the adjustment was outstanding
and he just continued to he really just
pounded the strikes up golden one now he
was four for four by the fifth inning
last night
let's see the communication between
shogo and goodwin it's good one peeling
off and one out
on base percentage for goldschmidt and
that is tops in baseball and it doesn't
matter if you're ahead in the count or
behind in the count this dude can hit
and it's a line drive that shogo akiyama
gloves a one two three first toy bottle
will lead off against 22 year old right
hander johan oviedo the upside is
tremendous for oviedo yeah this was a
name we started hearing in the winter as
a guy that's coming on quickly big
strong guy throws hard good off speed
pitch two to go with that fastball and
just a matter of him getting experience
battle goes down to get it and a ground
ball to goldschmidt he'll take it
himself and there's the out and there's
one away linker's back in the lineup
tonight after serving his one game
suspension yesterday however here's a
fastball grounded to short right field
where wong is playing and the second
baseman throws out the left hand at
batting jesse winker the lead off second
and brad miller swinging a hot bat after
last night pretty much everyone in
cardinal's lineup swinging a hot bat but
it was miller who set a new career high
with seven rbis last night 3-1 pitch
and miller hits one out to center it's
at the wall
gone
dead center field
miller
crushed it
number five on the year and they can't
get this guy out
brad miller
crushed it
one-nothing cardinals
that's a bomb
a bomb when he hit this you started
saying well i said no this ball is way
gone and by the way
on his wikipedia page guess what it says
this week i own the reds he is also the
owner of the cincinnati reds
suarez mustaches brian goodwin due up
here in the second now the 3-1 to suarez
this one's ripped into left center field
that'll find the gap up against the wall
suarez on his way to second base and the
tying run is in scoring position the
reds have him at the corners now with
nobody out the batter's brian goodwin
and the 2-2
struck him out catches the outside
corner and jose garcia comes up with the
pitches swung out and missed a slider
that was in the strike zone back-to-back
strikeouts goodwin and garcia and here
is akiyama with first and third two down
base hit
past the diving long this will tie the
game at one so a clutch two out hit show
goal we're underway here in the bottom
of the third inning vado castillanos and
winker to face johann oviedo
as bottle strikes out nick castellanos
bounced out in the first and he's locked
in now and he paints the outside corner
and strikes out castellanos on three
pitches and he blew him away
my goodness it's like a different guy
from last time
fifth inning 1-1 our score
and molina jumps on the pitch out to
left it is gone
a home run yadier molina
the cardinals have a couple of hits
and a couple of solo home runs and it's
2-1
red birds
molina's second home run of the year and
against the reds that's his 25th and
mally knew it immediately his reaction
diminity through the pitch almost before
yachty made contact he bowed his head
down and just knew that it was not going
to be a good result from his point of
view but thomas just got under it here's
colton wong wong is o for two runner at
second two outs one two pitch and wong
sends it out to left center that is down
gets passed goodwin
and wong winds up at second base big two
out hit it's a two run lead and it's 3-1
saint louis the 1-1
[Applause]
floater
mike mustakas climbs the ladder that was
a great play i didn't think he was going
to get it he says a moose doesn't have
ups we'll see if the reds can cash in
now runner on with one out here's tucker
barnhart
here's the 1-0 barnhart swings and
drives one pretty deep to center field
hit well backing up thomas at the wall
he leaps it is gone tucker barnhart he
ties it up at three with a two run blast
to straight away center field fastball
down and away and tucker barnett's all
over it john gant in for lewis 10 and a
third thus far and a 1.74 era and now
the reds have a little mini rally going
with two outs here in the seventh two on
two out
first and second and the batter is jesse
winker gant delivers swing and a miss
and winker goes down another 3-2 pitch
coming to winker here it comes and it's
a called strike three on the inside
corner perfectly placed by john gant he
catches winker looking
and that is a huge pitch in this game
gamber into the ball game for the
cardinals with one out and nobody on the
next two mustaches
and a grounder backhanded by wong
what a play oh my goal glover comes up
with another beauty on a ball hit hard
to his right he throws out
the bases are loaded with one out for
tyler o'neill the pitch
he struck him out he blew a fastball by
him he still needs one more big out and
that is lane thomas
[Applause]
a miss good job iglesias strikes out
back-to-back batters to strand three
winning run in scoring position with
fato coming to the plate i think you win
it right here yes the most walk-off hits
in great american ballpark history and a
right center field here comes akiyama
rounding third throw to the plate and
walk it off joey vado
told you
get akiyama in scoring position the guy
with the chip on his shoulder comes
through
big time
high fives all around bravado
as the reds win it 4-3